get to a safe distance
[Music]
now I am become film theorist
destroyer of childhoods
foreign
ternet welcome to film Theory the show
that sometimes actually talks about
films Hey look it's not my fault that
most of the interesting stuff these days
is happening on the internet but
shockingly enough between all the shorts
and Toilet Wars Hollywood finally
managed to produce a movie that caught
all of our attention Oppenheimer and
honestly with Hollywood strikes nowhere
close to ending this is probably one of
the last times we'll actually get to
talk about a new movie for a while so
let's just do that shall we let's
theorize for a bit about Oppenheimer
because spoiler alert it's not actually
about the Title Character now for those
of you who aren't looking to pay 20
bucks to go see three hours of men
dramatically talking at each other this
is the latest movie from director
Christopher Nolan and it's all about the
life of J Robert Oppenheimer a brilliant
scientist who was recruited by the US
government in World War II to develop
the atomic bomb well a great deal of the
film covers the development of the bomb
most of the drama actually comes into
play with the Fallout of the bomb pun
definitely intended you see Oppenheimer
felt intense guilt for the creation of
his weapon fearing that the escalation
of nuclear weaponry would lead to
worldwide Annihilation and so he used
his influence to try to get the United
States to back off from the arms race
that he himself inadvertently created of
course this doesn't sit too well with
the powers that be and they ultimately
tried to discredit him for their own
political gain it is heavy stuff with a
lot of super serious themes on its mind
personally though my favorite part of
the whole thing was when Oppenheimer
said it's up in time then he opt all
over the screen it's completely
unexpected very good twist in the third
act but like I alluded to in the intro I
think there's more going on here oh sure
it's an incredible commentary on the
effects of power whether or not we
should be toying with destructive atomic
energy and how ambition can Cloud your
judgment but underneath the surface
there's a second story going on here a
meta story I believe that Oppenheimer is
not just an overt biopic about the
father of the atomic bomb I also think
it's a secret biopic about the man who
made it the director Christopher Nolan
himself and what's more if you look at
the direction oppenheimer's life took in
the film it tells us exactly what's next
for Nolan in his career here the hint
for you
oh yeah so strap on your goggles and
don't look directly at the explosion
friends it's time to set this Theory off
so I imagine your first thought here is
probably huh suggesting that no one's
making a movie this meta doesn't really
seem like the sort of thing that this
super serious director would do does it
but you would think so but here's the
thing he's done it before Nolan's first
big budget movie after he hit the
mainstream with Batman Begins and The
Dark Knight was Inception now if you
don't know Inception you most definitely
know its influence memes about this
thing were everywhere it is the sole
reason that every trailer from the 20
teens had those blahs in them you know
the ones
[Music]
foreign
Inception was a classic Heist film with
a Twist the heists were happening inside
of Dreams it's a really cool film and a
truly pioneered a visual style that
would influence movies like Doctor
Strange in the years that would follow
but it was also one of the first and
biggest movies to truly lean into Theory
culture for instance the movie ends on
this big Cliffhanger that if you pay
enough attention to the small details
like a true theorist throughout the rest
of the movie you can actually solve and
that wasn't it years and years ago there
was this popular Theory a fan Theory
going around suggesting that the entire
movie was actually one big allegory for
the art of filmmaking with each of the
main characters representing a different
member of the film's crew he had the
extractor organizing the whole thing
representing a film's director the point
man who did all the research
representing producers the architect who
created the dreams themselves
representing the production designer the
forger to impersonate others in the
dream representing actors a benefactor
financing the whole project and meddling
a little bit more than they probably
should representing the studios even the
mark that they were implanting the ideas
into representing the audience of the
movie being affected by the film's ideas
it was a really cool really classic film
theory that believe it or not Nolan
himself actually confirmed he explained
that Inception was a reflection of his
artistic life and that he wrote the
team-based collaborative activity from
the movie based on the team-based
collaborative process that he knew
filmmaking which just goes to show us
two separate things first sometimes
those super out their theories aren't as
wrong as you think and two Nolan isn't
afraid to use allegories about making
movies in his movies so now that we've
established that fact how can we map
Nolan's life on Oppenheimer while
Oppenheimer is praised as a thought
leader in his field he's brilliant a
true Visionary who's able to get the job
done all of that Maps pretty perfectly
on Nolan who's undeniably one of the
best most respected directors currently
working today just like Opie Nolan is a
great leader with other professionals
who are very eager to work with him I
mean just look at the star power and
Oppenheimer that are basically regulated
to cameos and background extras a great
specific example of this a few years ago
Matt Damon was taking a break from
acting to spend time with his family he
negotiated with his wife that the only
thing that would get him to end his time
off early was if Christopher Nolan
called right before Nolan offered him
his part in Oppenheimer but Nolan's got
this respect from being a thought leader
who's Unapologetic for his work in a
cinema ecosystem where only established
IP gets substantial budgets Nolan is
able to get almost any project that he
wants funded again it's just like
Oppenheimer who at the beginning of his
career was considered to be out there
with his theories but by the end of it
was getting huge funding for his
Manhattan Project and you cannot deny
that both of these men get explosive
results since Batman Begins Nolan's
films almost universally get tons of
prestige and money as for Oppenheimer
his explosive results are measured in
you know the actual explosions but for
all the good that Nolan and Oppenheimer
share you could argue that they also
share a lot of the bad for instance ego
and self-importance were oppenheimer's
biggest flaws it had to be his way or
the highway map of that on Nolan well
one could look at the disastrous
decision to release the movie tenet in
theaters in September of 2020 at the
height of the covid-19 pandemic as one
article so succinctly put it quote I
don't want to die for Chris Nolan's ego
sounds a lot like something someone
might might say about Oppenheimer
doesn't it another example of Nolan's
brilliant stubbornness are all the
criticisms around his sound mixing on
multiple movies due to quote artistic
choices Hall of Nolan's most recent
films have been criticized for having
dialogue that's borderline impossible to
hear as Forbes put it quote I don't know
what Chris Nolan has against dialogue
there were widespread reports of
audiences having trouble hearing several
characters speak in The Dark Knight
Rises Interstellar Dunkirk tenant and
Oppenheimer Nolan has gone on record
saying that he knows that his movies
will be watched across all sorts of
different screens in good Cinemas and
bad theaters televisions iPhones but is
one sound professional who works with
him put it quote I know Nolan does like
to push the envelope he's an artist and
I don't think he believes in working to
the lowest common denominator sounds
like a person whose ego doesn't allow
him to compromise kind of like a certain
scientist pursuing results no matter the
odds so you can certainly see that
there's at least some parallels between
these two men but what about their
stories well follow me here with the
dramatized version of Opie's life from
the movie tracks really nicely with
Nolan's career both have humble
beginnings and Advance through their
respective Fields through smarts hard
work and talent both are hungry and
aspire to Greatness eventually catching
the attention of bigger players for
Oppenheimer his Brilliance makes him a
candidate to lead a secret program by
the American government for Nolan his
track record makes him a serious
Contender to direct bigger and bigger
movies for mainstream Hollywood Studios
where he eventually gets swept up by
Warner Brothers and both men have
themselves their pet Ambitions one of
oppenheimer's biggest goals early in his
career was to Pioneer the study of
physics in the United States He
specifically turns down offers to teach
in research in Europe because he wanted
to build an American program that would
become a scientific leader similarly
Nolan views himself as a Pioneer in the
use of camera technology and film
specifically the IMAX camera to get
larger than life shots in his movies
every single one of his movies since the
Dark Knight has used this technology and
IMAX has since become a staple of big
budget cinematic experiences which leads
us then to the biggest part of this
whole thing the bomb for Oppenheimer his
bomb is easy it is literally the atomic
bomb which would change the course of
his life forever for Nolan though his
Atomic weapon is a bit more symbolic his
bomb is the superhero Mega franchise
specifically Batman which would also
forever change the course of his career
here we have two leaders with incredibly
specific and different visions of how
they go about things against protocol
Oppenheimer gathers the most Brilliant
Minds that he can find regardless of
their gender and past affiliations
wrangling them all together in Los
Alamos the middle of nowhere and in a
world increasingly moving towards CGI
and special effects action Nolan's
Batman movies were really grounded they
were down to earth they were practically
shot and in the end both men's methods
work the Oppenheimer LED Trinity test
produces the atomic bomb and the
nolan-led movie production created The
Dark Knight trilogy which became some of
the most successful movies of the 2000s
but what happens after this incredible
success the people who funded those
projects turn around and use them in
ways that Nolan and Oppenheimer don't
approve of both the United States and
other countries like the Soviet Union
kept pushing the development of these
Atomic explosives much to oppenheimer's
horror while Warner Brothers and other
major motion picture studios kept
creating massive superhero films using
the dark night as their template one
specific parallel that I could draw here
is President Truman standing in for
Warner Brothers without oppenheimer's
knowledge or consent bombs created at
Los Alamos were deployed in the field
meanwhile WB took their entire 2021
movie slate and dropped it onto HBO Max
without consulting any of their partners
that moved specifically appalled Nolan
who felt blindsided by that decision and
he ditched Warner as a partner likewise
the government's decision to use the
bombs instead of sharing the knowledge
to The Wider World led to a rift between
Oppenheimer and the military as his
advice was ignored and he was pushed
further and further away from the
decision-making process years and years
later after the dust settles both men
returned to what they were doing before
Oppenheimer teaches and Nolan returns to
movie making outside the franchise
ecosystem it is movies like Dunkirk and
Tennis but despite this they both
continue to work against their former
benefactors they've already spoken about
how Nolan and WB had a falling out but
oppenheimer's insistence to speak out
against the h-bomb program earned him
the ire of government figures like Louis
Strauss and his security clearance was
revoked in an embarrassing semi-public
trial and you see this is where we're at
Nolan's story currently despite the bad
blood our Strauss stand in Warner
Brothers is trying to woo him back to
work on their projects but our
allegorical Oppenheimer Christopher
Nolan isn't really interested in doing
things the way they want to Nolan just
flat out is not interested in working on
the studio superhero Mega franchises
anymore and he's Keen to let the world
know it during the Press tour for
Oppenheimer when asked if he would do
any more superhero films Nolan replied
with a very quick and Curt no after
Batman do you want to direct another
superhero movie no and it's obvious to
see why I mean just look at what these
Mega franchises have done to cinema the
past few years we've talked about it a
lot on this channel already but studios
are pumping more and more money into
their Big Brand driven super powered
action movies Chase in the box office
numbers pulled in by those Dark Knight
films but that just isn't a sustainable
model in a lot of ways those early Chris
Nolan Batman movies set off a chain
reaction that ultimately led to massive
bombs like the flash earlier this year
to me this is actually the most
compelling comparison between these two
men froppy there was this worry that the
atomic test at Los Alamos was going to
set off a chain reaction that would
ignite the atmosphere and destroy the
world now obviously that didn't end up
happening but in the most chilling scene
in the whole movie Oppenheimer tells us
that he's afraid that he did set off a
chain reaction that would destroy the
world it wasn't one bomb it was
unlocking the power of the atom in
general leading to bigger and bigger
Weaponry that would ultimately lead to
nuclear Annihilation Nolan meanwhile
inadvertently set off a similar Chain
Reaction across Hollywood with all the
money now getting funneled into Mega
franchises he effectively helped to kill
off the low and mid-budget movies that
started his career and now as those big
movies fail one after the other the
industry as a whole is collapsing the
world of Hollywood has literally been
set on fire that being said this is
where our big twist to this whole
allegory comes in because Oppenheimer
the film has so many parallels to
Nolan's own life we can actually use the
end of Opie's story to predict what
Nolan is gonna do next clearly Nolan
isn't done with big Budget Cinema and
he's doing his best to use his name to
pull weight within the world of
filmmaking Nolan will want to pull
things back to a reasonable scale
telling stories that are good while also
pushing the art form forward and to do
it just like Oppenheimer tried to join
the development of the hydrogen bomb to
steer it in a direction he preferred I
suspect Nolan will be going back to the
mega franchises in fact I think we can
even pinpoint which ones he's gonna do
hear me out and quote me later
Christopher Nolan will direct a Star
Wars movie also a James Bond movie why
those two specifically well first of all
the James Bond project would fit Nolan's
down-to-earth style perfectly he's even
expressed interest in it during the
Press store for Oppenheimer he said this
I love those movies the the influence of
those movies on my filmography is
embarrassingly apparent it would be an
amazing privilege to do one but the more
interesting Direction here the
possibility of a Christopher Nolan Star
Wars film you see like so many of us
here on the internet Nolan has some
strong capital O opinions about the Star
Wars franchise especially what makes
them so successful the way he sees it a
lot of people think that the Star Wars
franchise has only worked because of its
story and he disagrees with that
entirely he thinks that while the plot
is important these sorts of movies also
need to push technology along to make
something new and cool with its visual
effects it has to be spectacle alongside
story and by the looks of it he's not
just interested in diagnosing the
problem it seems like he's interested in
finding the Cure himself during that
same interview where he said Point Blank
that he wouldn't do any more superhero
movies Nolan specifically declined to
answer when he was asked about Star Wars
would you like to make a Star Wars movie
pass sounds to me like someone who's in
negotiations with Disney which makes me
wonder will Nolan be able to make it
happen if he is able to make more movies
in these Mega franchises will he be able
to steer them into something better
something more meaningful something more
cinematic or will his guidance be
ignored just like oppenheimer's was but
hey that's just a theory a film Theory
and cuts and hey if you want to check
out some of our older film theories
about the Chris Nolan Batman movies that
started this whole Chain Reaction why
not check out our video about how the
Joker is secretly a billionaire or if
you want a really old school classic
film Theory check out the video about
how Batman actually destroyed Gotham in
The Dark Knight Rises
[Music]